Matthew you and I have made a lot of
progress together and you should be
proud of that yeah I'm proud of our work
but I do think it's time we address the
elephant in the room you're crippling
fear of clowns okay getting in the way
of your life your work your
relationships we need to start
addressing it this is my idea this is a
clown nose Oh relax with me okay okay
okay okay this is called exposure
therapy yeah the idea is if you can be
calm and relaxed in front of a small
piece of a clown we'll be one step
closer to being calm and relaxed in
front of an entire clown okay okay so
look right at it it's not dangerous it's
not coming at you I like it I know but
remember to breathe you stop breathing
there you go
I'm with you I'm right here with you
okay now I'm gonna sing something
remember to breathe and to relax okay
okay do-do breathe breathe breathe
do-do-do-do-do relax relax calmed and
relaxed calm and relaxed top you gotta
stop I can't take it it's freaking me
out he's freaking me out okay I
understand I'll go get Deb okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry
no don't don't apologize okay you did
fantastic yeah that was even better than
I thought you should do on your first
time feel good you feel that that's
progress okay yeah I want you to feel
like we did progress now let's just
start over okay breathe let's relax
let's close your eyes that's right
that's right close your eyes relax you
are in a safe place let's move past the
clowns okay all I want to do I want to
spend the rest of the session just
relaxing and getting you on with the
rest of your day okay that's good good
good good good good good good let's
relax
let's move Pat's clowns and now let's
open our eyes oh no I can't do that
good luck okay all right okay okay okay
all right I'm with you I'm looking this
is how you do this this is that thanks
this this is actually not so bad I can I
can become I can look at this I can see
you and I'm calm and I'm okay
a with it this is actually working thank
you you ah yeah that's our time why did
I use real blood